welcome welcome to your mom's house
[Music]
all right we did a bunch of stuff and
now we're back from me that's a good one
we took a break we had do stuff and then
there's okay no I'm glad to be here I
missed you I miss you you were gone he
went to fart Nix I did the second to
last stop on this tour and then we're
going to Hawaii tomorrow hop excite I
know what are you gonna do on your vacay
take it easy vape drink just chill
are you gonna be one of those dads
that's at the bar at 10:00 a.m. when it
opens why shouldn't I be I'm celebrating
the year the years over that always
amazes me those people on like look
everyone does their thing on vacation
but that to me is like real endurance
the people that like I'm just saying
like a Bert Kreischer maybe you know
yeah at the bar when it opens 10:00 a.m.
until Sunday Lou full-day it's gonna be
remember those dad's in the Dominican
Republic we went there and they found
out we had a porno Channel and they're
like what yeah there are so gels and
they were eyeballing the the girl that
was taking our photos remember the oh
yeah you young girl and he was like
check out hey get over here about yeah
they're like really dad and down on her
it's so sad when you become a dad yeah
do you feel sad yet yeah of course does
that dad sadness - oh yeah it's coming
out of my pores
what is the dad sadness about just
realize that fun's over and
responsibility yeah now you gotta like
make sure everyone's okay and make sure
lights are on food in the house just
yeah mom sadness is is there too where
you're like my body's destroyed and I
worry constantly about else no more joy
no more yeah that's so true
mmm I mean I I don't think I really have
fun do you do we have fun um no we don't
have fun this might be like the most fun
thing we do yeah that's probably why
we've kept it up for so long I'm sure
it's why yeah yeah we enjoy doing this
right but but in terms of scheduling fun
a vacation is imperative you have
to schedule big game it doesn't matter
where you're at in life I'm saying like
if you go a big Haitians expensive if
your vacation is just staying home not
doing anything and driving to get ice
cream at night and that's your big that
you need to do it you have to take a
break yeah take a break I think it's
better to leave though it's always
better to leave the home base because
I've done the home vacay thing too and
then you just get wrapped up in your
traditional drama it's true
all right let's do a traditional oh yeah
let's get into it I was taking a nap he
had come home farted at me after I I
assumed I just need to make sure I'm
hearing this correctly did you fart in
her face Oh Andy don't bring anyone love
into this
[Music]
I was just laughing at Twitter that's
all what what did you like because I had
wrote a tweet it to that kid that got
bullied yeah and I guess it got tweeted
it retweeted a good bunch no I wrote
right right his name's Keaton if you
haven't seen it there's this kid and he
he makes this tells his mom that like
kids are bullying me in school and it's
really he gets real emotional and he
talks about how how it's the kids are so
mean and he's like I don't understand
when they do it so people are just
different and she was like what did they
say to you and he he tells her like they
called me ugly and they're just really
mean it's like a heartbreaking video and
since she posted it went viral and like
everyone is inviting this kid to shit
like Tennessee Titans bring him to
football game right I know celebrities
are on but isn't that kind of bullying
of the mother to post a very vulnerable
it's in a while isn't that not
protecting him yeah I mean willing him
hit but anyways he what you exactly
you're saying yeah I wouldn't do that
I'll be like mom don't fucking post that
yeah you're an asshole for blood it
worked out in this way so he's got
Cavaliers invite him to a game three or
four movie stars have invited him to
movie premieres Chris Evans what's his
name forget the fucking guy's name then
Dana White invited them to a UFC
headquarters so he's like everyone's
reaching out this kid so I just stopped
for a second today and I wrote hey
Keaton don't get too too full of
yourself with all this attention I will
fuck you up and there's not a thing your
mom or LeBron or Chris Evans can do
about it and that's it it's funny yeah
and it's good right now it's got about
3,000 retweets and 8,000 likes the the
comments underneath that are hilarious
because people are either being like
hell yes and getting that that's a joke
or and putting like funny memes and
gifts under it or they're being like
really taking it very seriously like you
know you're what's wrong
not you know that's not funny who made
you do this like just shit like that so
it's just funny and then I saw some guy
people are clowning the
also started like a GoFundMe the mother
did so what happened because I follow
this Instagram account Hollywood um
unlocked or something yeah
and that UFC guy was on there saying
that he invited that boy but the mother
was like don't invite him I'm not
letting him go but you can promote my
GoFundMe page yeah and then he goes for
what and she's like well christmas is
coming and I'm a single mother and I
want money for my kids fame so she's
really really ruining this for her son
by the way yeah that's she's not cool so
then other people started GoFundMe for
being bullied but they're they're making
a mockery of it like this this guy here
[Laughter]
looking out of like window blinds yeah
nigga stay bullying me and shit and it's
a hundred thousand dollar goal how much
does he had so far but it really made me
laugh so yeah yeah man I love people's
internet internet things you know what I
mean like it's really healing the world
when you take a stand against shit like
oh come on dude I think it's funny I'm
opposed to the terrorist attacks well of
course everyone is I think it's funny
people take this seriously that means
that take my tweets right right what are
you talking about like yeah well that's
you know that's what's gonna that's what
divides us yeah that's what that's
that's the you know I tell you the
Internet is pretty miraculous and that
it exposes the humanity of everyone and
the joy and then the absolute dumb
fuckery of I'd say 80% I'd say we're at
80% retarded for the world what do you
think I think when people I think the
greatest I've said this before the
greatest indicator of stupidity is when
you don't process when something is
clearly a joke yeah so there are so many
people that don't process don't
understand don't register sarcasm or
satire right irony none of it none of it
goes through their head that's the
greatest indicator
stupid person that and I would say the
folks who belong that God is extending
hurricanes or fires because of what gays
are doing like my mom what does she
really think that it's to punish the
gays and stuff no no no fuckers no shits
the buggers it's that we need to be
better people to each other all right
we're not being good to each other were
I'm like yeah yeah and then she's like
and you know these hurricanes and I'm
like God teaching us a lesson huh yep
well how come he doesn't reward us when
stuffs going well well he does life the
wouldn't look it was amazing stuff
waters everywhere
yeah there's stuff like that I talked
about it on stage about her POV of that
I didn't do this weekend but I have been
doing it and about how at a cert like
you you have this conversation with her
and I at twenty two or three I am going
to make sure every point that I have
about that is expressed now boy and I
know it's going to build into a fight
you tell me now they think God sends the
fires and I think about the energy it
would take to have that argument and
then I just go like yeah yeah isn't that
the essence of middle age or approaching
middle age I guess so is where you you
just you do the math tired of the
exhaustion mentally and spiritually that
would take mmm-hmm like that's where the
they're not giving a Fox is awesome of
this age of your life yeah there's so
many things I don't fucking care about
anyway no things that used to really
wind me up you know I don't I just don't
have the energy either I could by the
way it's so funny that this was a clip I
could charge you with assault for what
you just did it's literally you had no
idea this was what was planned no it's
literally a dead part of the show today
Vincent is suing his former roommate
Ortiz in the amount of 596 dollars he
says after pulling a prank on the
defendant she viciously attacked him
risen and she did yeah
from the fart and well the retaliation
my roommate and my sister knew him all
right well how did the two end up
getting gypped basically it's gonna
sound a little gross but Vince is
lactose intolerant and I don't know why
given his age he's not in third grade
anymore but I like ice cream your honor
so I can cut we're getting into that he
purposely ate some ice cream right and
he's lactose intolerant he knows what's
gonna happen
he knows what ice cream does to him
because he's lactose intolerant and he
tends to I know what like I scream I
don't however I don't like having ice
cream thrown at my face and that's
actually what she can already tell he's
a liar actually I think he's full of
shit yeah sorry that I was taking a nap
he had come home farted at me after I I
assume well I just need to make sure I'm
hearing this correctly did you fart in
her face moments before this podcast
started you had sat here I did he
recorded some ads and then I said hey I
need to sit here to get back into this
show you stood up and right here you
farted a disgusting front and I farted
on your shoulder though not in your face
okay let the judge explain some things
to you
did you smell my fart of course is
horrible what'd it smell like anything
in your presence regarding this farting
oh boy has there so this is the sister
now weighing in on the dart and that
he's a habitual farter that seems to be
a regular part of his act he did make a
lot of fart jokes during his act and he
does tend to fart a lot on purpose you
know there's the occasional slip-up but
he does think it's funny to fart on
people it is funny it is funny about
that I'm not arguing that I mean if
we're in the court of what's funny I'd
say this guy wins yeah there's any
evidence in the testimony before this
court the gavel is going to come down
and pay for the defendant because that
everyone that was talking not real crazy
about you you're a little mouthy but
your sister she was saw so but then one
last thing here really ranking those
four menses that's the judge says I
think maybe you should pay attention to
realize it or not when I talked about
the chain of events when you farted in
her I was in assault assault you have to
put your hands up some 100 to assault
them a fart is an assault a fart is an
assault well that's interesting we
learned something new every day on this
show yeah every every week rather so did
i assault you that's what you're
claiming of course an assault yeah you
did yeah you didn't rape her face what
are the damages what are the damages I
don't know a million dollars a million
dollars was disgusting up for B for my
emotional distress oh sure
what did I what did I stop you from
doing in your life from getting my mind
together
there was nothing confusing about well
what did it smell like let's talk about
my fart it smelled really disgusting it
really did well like what like sour shit
yeah yeah why because I went to the
salad bar and I I get my thousand ranch
dressing I make it at Gelson's I thought
of another one by the way what where we
were talking earlier about things that
we think we are yes
like you know when you when you like
like it came up because it's had to is
you're like I want to get a tattoo like
that lady like you'll see somebody with
yeah
or something like it and you're like
well then you go but that's not me right
you know what I always wanted want to be
what sounds like the leather-bound daily
planner person I was that person once in
my life I bought them because I love I
love well I love luggage and I love you
know let like leather-bound anything
whether it's a backpack a briefcase like
I just I have like I kind of fetishized
romanticize any artisan work handmade
handcrafted you know I mean anything
like that I go like oh I want that thing
but you're also I get it and I and I
don't use it well yeah I give you stuff
that's leather-bound a lot I'm a bit
into it and then you this is all its are
you this is you this is a little wallet
I use of course but I'll hand you like a
new thing and you'll go oh thanks put it
down it's gone forever
mmm and anyway this yes this topic came
up in regards to the tattoo I mentioned
I wanted my midlife crisis tattoo yes
and I thought about it I got many on
your nipples no on my inner arm I
thought you're going to do 2% vitamin D
on this it's never two percent its all
full milk yeah and I came to the
conclusion that I I may want it but I'm
not the person who does it like meaning
I think I'm that girl right but the
truth of it is I shop at the gap and I'm
super boring and like I don't have the
cajon I wouldn't say you're boring I
would say that you just you don't
identify with that I'm too traditional
like part of me worries about being 80
years old and being in an airport cuz I
saw this woman at the airport who was
like 70 yeah with an asshole tattoo she
but she had something on her leg that
was so hideously inappropriate in her
age and I can't do it it's just not me
you know and there's a whole slew of
things I wish I could be I I wish I
could be the girl when they take photos
that they don't smile mmm like they just
look like their mouths yeah cool but I
always I'm like picture like I'm so I'm
like a Labrador I wanted to be the get
up and grind exercise guy like I
exercise I work out a lot
no I'm saying like I work out a lot
yeah but I've always read about and hear
about the guy that gets up at like 5:00
Oh like dont like Mark Wahlberg I
followed a mr. Graham he's up at 4:00
yeah what are you doing your life early
today sorry why I've tried it I hate it
that's terrible I have to work out in I
can work out in the morning after a
certain hour like at least eight I'd
rather work out at 11:00 because I need
to feel alive just to do it you know
well be there's people that wake up at
like 4:00 a.m. fuck that fuck that their
days start earlier but they don't they
work they start working like seven I
Santa sighs about like being yeah but
back that motivated guy that fucking
grinds it like from the before the Sun
comes up yeah oh god that sounds
terrible I the girl I also want to be as
the one that wears high heels mhm and
has like Beach wavy hair like she she
wakes up early and she curls it yeah and
then also is really into facial
treatments I like her where she she's
here she's not in this house oh oh oh
right and the girl who's like really up
on the facials and injections and like
really into like that level of self-care
you could be that girl yeah how much
energy that girl expensive shit yeah I
ain't got that kind of time
no I mean I I also fantasize about being
a motorcycle guy not like fucking like
in a bike gang like I'll see a beautiful
bike and I'll go like oh and I've never
ridden one and I don't really honestly
don't want to ride one when I when I see
them here on the 405 and like weaving
between cars what I do fantasize about
is the open road in like Wyoming you
know or you just see it like you just
picture open road maybe it's a maybe
it's on a ranch or something and there's
like some dirt trails and I fantasize
like that'd be cool I'd like to do that
but then I could say I'm not going to do
that you know but I still lose myself in
the thought and yeah cuz you'll see like
a picture of someone and you're like I
could be that person I have to stop
myself from buying luggage all the time
just because like it's
especially when it gets more niche-y you
know I was like I bought a suitcase for
our trip and they're like we have these
backpacks we have these shoulder packs
we have this so every time it's any type
of compartment you can get them like ah
yeah yeah I could put pens in that yeah
like I I just want I don't know I
fantasized that without being that
organized like that organizer just I
like compartmentalizing things you know
in a cool case you know I like a cool
box yeah it's almost like a gadget in a
way you know it's not a gadget but it's
like a cousin right right that like the
presentation of the things like why a
cool cigar box is cool it's yeah yeah I
got the cigar now you like the container
the container comes in yeah that's
interesting
yeah but then at the same time I'm aware
of myself enough to not overdo it so
I'll see that thing and I'll go like
yeah and then I go you know well the
thing to I've realized about my
personality is that I can only own like
five things at a time because I'll buy
I'll buy other stuff and then I'll
forget it I'll be like oh I have that so
or like I just don't I'll forget about
it I also only own five things I'm with
you on that I also feel like I'll buy
something nice like a nice shirt and
then I'll see it in the closet and I'll
go like oh right now I'm gonna run out
and go to the grocery store and then you
know run it I don't know run another
errand and I go put on that shirt then I
go but that's too nice of a shirt for
that errand I do that all the time yeah
where I'm saving the clothing for a
special occasion and then we go like I
do that all the time we're going to
dinner X right tonight like we're not
going to and I go but like yeah don't
fuck it up on the vacation yeah so I
better leave it here that's the problem
I do the same thing I have a coat that
you bought me a fancy coat and I haven't
found I found one occasion to wear it on
so far fucking find it no it's such a
bummer and it's the most beautiful coat
it is a beautiful coat it's like really
regretting it getting it for you thank
you and I inherited these ridiculous fur
coats from my mother when she died and
those just stay in my closet like there
is absolute
nowhere to wear a fur coat in Los
Angeles sorry
are you crazy only a crazy person buys
real fur coats yeah minks and shit
bizarre isn't this is not an official
dental update but as might as well
should be yes and press your fucking
teeth please press some goddamn teeth I
don't understand how you can walk around
and not brush up your teeth your breath
stank ain't good teeth the dirty no man
they have we're all you know I mean that
is a centum yeah yeah she was Jasmine
masters she was on RuPaul's Drag Race
just making sure yeah yeah yeah I like
to clarify my confusion in my brain
that's a good idea
but I like the message I'm trying board
100% with her hell yeah I'm gonna fix
that use a little Clorox if you have to
list the ring the brown guy so I could
get all straight through she's saying
she's sick she's sick of foul mouth man
you know who's she hanging out with I'll
just hang out with anyone CD to see that
you see people with funky ass and the
problem is what if you're close to one
of those and how do you tell them how do
you tell somebody my world you just
speak right up you know in comedian
world you can yeah you'd be like bro
shits all fucked up shit's all whack
I've told people you told parents oh
well that's different
you know your mom and dad you're
embarrassed about their mouths daily
yeah I'm always like are you guys gonna
address that they just laugh I know I
don't know if they actually do anything
no they do because they've told me my
dad called me he's like I just left the
dentist he told he called me that like a
month ago
oh he did yeah and how'd it go I don't
know I'm like did they rip all your
teeth out he's like now getting a clean
bill of health from like you're going to
a liar yeah he was a little anything
we're getting between them cheese brush
on the front in the back the size in
them teeth she's gonna I see it yeah I
was just noticing and flossing does she
doesn't even mention flossing that's the
key to good dental hygiene you probably
got hit on by someone with fucky-fucky
teeth that's a private
I mean it's like a event about inventing
about that happening yeah impression
Chris Malan that people with food of
your teeth that's like you please get it
together just thank you yeah yeah I
think that's what happened somebody was
like uh mmm that's terrible
I'm always so self-conscious about that
yeah
man had the coffee breath and stuff yeah
it's the first thing I do in the
mornings I mean I don't know how anybody
skips that step in the more Oh we were I
was tight old I talked about this years
ago on your mom's house but I need
somebody whose mother would only brush
her teeth once a day yeah and she would
wake up drink the coffee and then go all
day without brushing her teeth
that's real crazy real so then she would
brush like by five o'clock and they were
like you need to brush way but way
earlier how did did not bother you
that's the thing she's like it I don't
like she goes I don't like the flavor of
the toothpaste I don't like the taste of
toothpaste oh and they said well you
know you can get like cinnamon different
kinds get chocolate flavored whatever
and so they did they got her the flavor
she liked and then then she started
doing it but you know that's somebody's
mom bro it's really crazy that's a
lifetime Josh Weinstein was here last
week and here we go he promoted I need
you to kill the documentary that I'm in
I know I haven't seen it and I'm so bond
okay wait check it out a lot of people
have been messaging me that they watched
it so thank you you can rent it for a
few bucks so you can buy it it's
available on like all the pay-per-view
cable things it's on iTunes it's on
Amazon on IMDB some of our listeners got
into the trivia portion OD film oh dear
so they're adding things all the time
tom is a denim enthusiast who prefers
the white where high very tight fitting
jeans Tom lives a polyamorous bisexual
life or his life harder Christina they
have a son named Jean Tom considers
himself a mommy just like receipted as
they say there
- I was in one gene shot Thomas agro
began my career as a DJ named dad mouth
he gives his hands free tickets to DJ
gigs collaborates with luminaries like
obi-wan kenobe DJ duct tape McCauley
Zim's our young patriotic taping dad Tom
holds a yearly comedy benefit to support
the family of his dear friend Bert
Chrysler lost his battle with alcoholism
Jesus Christ
speaking of kill Tom's favorite movie is
Henry portrait of a serial killer yes
you just said that you watched something
about Ted Bundy that you thought was
riveting and hilarious Eimer
somebody tweeted you the Ted Bundy thing
I saw that on Twitter somebody said is
this a young teenage Tom and it was Ted
Bundy being led down some courthouse
stairs and there's like a kid in the
background smiling I think it was Vegas
702 love her yeah been around a long
time baby
this says also that Tom Segura found
Asia to be amazed he was inspired to go
on his trip by his spiritual adviser Kim
in so that's really asshole it's really
really nice of you to what do you think
that the Wikipedia is and the IMDb's of
the world will figure out that this
communal posting thing is not really
bringing forth truth in the world on the
know because my Wikipedia page says I
was born in Toronto and that is
inaccurate mine said fucking Dayton
doing this who's Windsor Ontario guys
glamorous Windsor Windsor cross four
five one three men date why yeah
come on now I'm not that classy to be
from the t dot yeah no I don't know
people can just add what they want and
it becomes a fact I know and then I do
all this press stuff and I'm like you're
born in Toronto wasn't it great I get
asked the Dayton thing every week you're
from Dayton I'm like dude I want the
dating the first time on 5:28 they're
like that's where you're from
yeah like Kim deal Kim deal from Dayton
Ohio Dayton Ohio what is this question
here somebody said is Joey Diaz insane
yeah I was listening on your recent
podcast was blown away when Joey
admitted to dropping a hot steamy brown
in the shower yeah and then physically
picking up with his bare hands and toss
it in the toilet what's even more
perplexing is that minutes after
admitting shitting in the shower three
times in his life he said he is quoted
to have said this is true you have to be
an animal to shit on an airplane yeah it
made my dad boner flaccid when I heard
this I was confused and disturbed I had
to change my pronoun why does he think
browning and a plain bathroom is so
repulsive but full-on shitting in the
shower picking it with your bare hands
is not I love the podcast I always look
forward to Joey stories please piss on
me and beat me from canvas
oh my god that's a new that's a new
greeting yeah that was hilarious piss on
me try it yeah try it out it's the best
part of that whole thing try it out come
over here
black guys won't fucking fuck oh good oh
my god do you want to fuck me come over
you won't get out of prison you got
friends it's my building try it out
looks like a piss let me try it out she
might only as fuck man I'm looking for
hardcore guys I mean it want to do it
and I want to show her I'm a hot pot my
trash come dump let's fuck okay he's
also like trying to say so much he's
like tripping over his own words he's so
excited he's going tribe from my fuck me
I mean it's really really fighting up
for it he's so excited to answer the
email question about Joey it's because
it's a lunatic person you're asking to
think irrationally yeah only somebody
that crazy will go like yeah I pick up
shits in my shower throw them into the
toilet but shitting on the plane of
course he's not a logical human being
well Joey's got his own code yeah it
makes sense to him yeah yeah what's
amazing about it well to be fair I think
every human has their own sense of
what's decent and what's not and it's
just Joey's logic you know dad's up that
way yeah yeah you know then again you
know I think I think shitting on a plane
is horrendous then again picking up a
loaf of shit and throwing it from the
shower into the toilet it's pretty
gnarly too I don't know oh yeah that's
true oh god
I had such a messy brown the other day
and I was so thankful for our bidets so
thankful there really are days we were
like how did we even white bow feels
like the downside of thinking about
Hawaii I'm like no no I'll be able to
wash my ass ever I really love it you
know it's interesting I was talking to
you the other day about when I was
pregnant with Ellis how I could really
smell things like me yeah but pregnant
lady smell and I remember when you would
fart I could smell the layers to it like
some of it was nutty sometimes so cool
earthy so cool I could smell the oak
tones I could smell the and then you go
like a fart sommelier yeah and I thought
what a neat what a neat title and
somebody out there is a fart so Mollier
yeah you are what you mean somebody out
there you are you're a fart someone yeah
only if I'm pregnant because that's
that's like a pregnant lady's
superpowers there's smell yeah but no
youyou are a fart so more yes I will say
that when I go take when I go in the
bathroom after you've taken a dump yeah
you're after dump smells are sweet oh I
don't know what it is but your Browns
have either a very sour quality when
they're sick you know when you've eaten
shellfish or something but they're
generally very sweet diabetes yeah we're
supposed to be joined here any moment by
the great Pauly Shore I'd say I grew up
watching him I don't know were you
watching MTV back fuck yeah man oh my
god that and the movies I love this
Jesus Christ you know my dad's favorite
movie is son-in-law son-in-law was great
which is you know man hilarity no man
was great which is funny because my dad
obviously has that cultural divide of
you know being like a hardcore Hungarian
yeah and it was so funny to always
walking on him just hysterically
laughing at Pauly Shore and son-in-law
yeah those guys so stupid he just loved
it yeah yeah so foreigners really are
into you let's take a quick break
he should be here any moment okay mommy
take a break from there okay all right
so that was uh that was exactly the
right time to take that shit out perfect
and I have to say he was on time so
we're here with the great Polly short
thanks for coming over this is exciting
since Tommy gave you paid ray groups I
know we keep missing each other but I
seen you around once in a while but
that's hilarious it's pretty surreal
been pretty surreal that you're here no
I mean for both of us because yeah we
both like we both grew up in the MTV era
you and I were talking once in the green
room at the store about you know a lot
of the stuff you've done but even with
the movies and everything if you go back
to people that grew up with like MTV as
like the cool thing dude the VJs thing
is crazy like for people that are I
don't know under 30 listening or
watching right now they don't they have
no idea what MTV was MTV was the only
cool outlet there well it was like
there's there's like there's the network
shows there's like a couple cable things
there's only like fun it wasn't be cool
like whatever that was cool was MTV and
I think Polly you tapped into it like
with the weasel it was like the first on
how you say hilarious you know it was
like you know it's it's like a viral
video it's like you know I did a Stephen
Miller video I don't know a couple
months ago and it just it took off and
then you do another video and it doesn't
take off and it's like MTV
well everything lined up for me and
everything everything lined up for what
was happening at the time I mean MTV was
very East Coast if you think back it was
like you know Ken over and and and I
don't know I mean fuck this downtown
Julie brown
it was coast and then I'd love her yeah
other dr. Dre yeah and then I was
sitting there I'm like fuck I got to get
on there and then it just you know I
don't know break down the whole story
but once they got on there it was
something that was completely different
and and the timing for me I was
developing my stand-up I was 17 when I
first started doing stand-up and then
and then my timing I think I was like 20
when I got on I mean you have to
understand something Wow
I was on MTV in my 20s that's my 20
that's why your balls are drained there
must have been so much yeah my 20s yeah
wait no and movies all my movies was in
my 20s it's not like I did my movies in
my 30s my career like started to go you
know down when I like had my run-in in
my 30s okay you know I mean that's after
all the movies and all the all the stuff
like that's when I stopped getting
offers and all that shit yeah dude offer
stop because of like a bad like because
movies the movie business is real crazy
in that it's like just like an standup
it's like ticket salesman I think I
think I just didn't do what Dave
Chappelle did which was he stopped while
he was ahead uh-huh for me you know I
mean and this should be a learning
lessons to everyone out there when your
stock is high like back off you know
like stop like like for instance like I
could have stopped after son-in-law my
dad's favorite movie by the way we just
fantastic it's hilarious it's a fun
thank you thank you
it's a great movie you made a lot of
great movies yeah I made I made some
really fun movies like I like I like and
I see my movies now and I love all of
them but my point is is that I wasn't
thinking all I want to do is work right
do you mean like like like they're like
oh you're gonna star in a movie and it's
gonna be about you're gonna be on jury
duty and there's gonna be Stanley
Tucci's in it and you got all these
great actors in it and and you know Tia
Carrere
awful Wayne's World and blah blah I'm
like fuck that sounds good of course
jury duty sounds hilarious right but you
know I didn't work good with the
director the the perdu the script was
weird the you know everything with like
didn't line up it wasn't like it lined
up on my other films and because I was a
but my name was above the title
I fucking suffered from it right you
only mean by the way I've always wanted
to ask this to somebody with your like
with the experience of doing that when
you're making a movie do you the best
thing in the world I imagine that
literally the best thing in the world
you ever have any sense when the movies
being shot do you sense like
this is not gonna go well like you feel
that on the ones that China you do yeah
kinda but then you also it's like when I
did I bring back the Stephen Miller
video just because it was my last recent
thing that did well like I did that and
I didn't know I was gonna wind up on CNN
being talking to like one of the CNN
news 8 that was really funny for people
that don't know though Stephen Miller
works in the Trump administration he's
one of the presidential aides and he
came out and like basically took the mic
one day this is on the way of Spicer
going out and really talked a lot of
shit to a lot of the reporter larious
and Polly did like a parody of it where
he had like the the fucking horseshoe
the bald head and yeah it's very funny
man yes thank you thank you can people
see that but my point is is that you do
things in you you know you can't control
all the other antics that happens so you
can just do what you do and then and
then it's like it's in God's hands yeah
you know as far as a hit you just don't
know don't know when you have an outcome
now you don't know but in retrospect you
feel like you would have strategized in
terms of like absolutely I'll take my
agents and managers told me not to do it
oh of course
they're like you know even when I did in
the army now they told me not to do that
because I got a I just signed a
three-picture deal at Disney and I
didn't see no man first I did son-in-law
and the next they won't with Jeffrey
Katzenberg who was running Disney at the
time wanted me to do another movie there
and new line came to me with this other
film called totally London which was
basically me playing an au pair in
London you know like Polly Poppins like
oh I know where I go over there you know
with my slang and whatever it is and I
live with this kind of English family
and and we wanted to do that but because
I was in bed with Disney and Jeffrey
Katzenberg they wouldn't get me out of
that deal so Jeffrey said shut up you're
gonna do this movie and that's when we
did in the army now and in the army now
did well like now it's made its money
after years of it being out there but at
the time it didn't do as good as the
other movies did so that was like and
then I cut my hair and I was so known
for my hair yes can we please talk about
are we gonna cut the LEAs hair yeah we
gotta take it up cuz he's getting too
much babes bro
for me yone me many babes yeah that
doesn't work for me so can we talk
because he the I feel like the weasel
you could have found that guy anywhere
on the sunset sunset strip in that era
of time because it was like the the
metal clubs you remember like the Sunset
Strip was kind of that dude very well
could have been living there yeah how
did you how did he come to you well
first of all before you even answer that
can we start so that people know that
Paulie like where he grew up
oh my god craziest life ever like they
taste like so that they know the
background your your mother Mitzi shore
the oh my god yeah it just goes don't
bring me in on this bullshit mom you
know ran the Comedy Store and probably
basically grew up at the comic store yes
of course and and I met your debt and
and there's you know he's got Sam
Kinison babysitting room and crazy and
Rodney and just as craziest Rodney was
the best really oh my god so hilarious
just oh yeah oh yeah he was the best I
believe that yeah he was the best and
sweetheart and funny and all that stuff
to Cristina's point do you at an early
age because it's almost it seems normal
to you do you go like I'm gonna do this
I'm gonna do with all these people might
I have two brothers and a sister and
they're not into it so it's like they
grew up in it as well I mean you guys
know you guys are straight comics you
guys are hardcore comics like you don't
choose it it chooses you like like you
live fuckin in the valley like you guys
have to drive to the calmness or deal do
you think you like driving the comedy
store no yeah but you fucking know once
you get up there gonna have that feeling
and that you know that especially you
guys got to drive to the fucking Airport
yeah and fly to you know all over
America do you like that no but you know
what's gonna happen when you get there
right people are gonna be there for you
and your heart is gonna be open you're
gonna feel this like stress reliever
you don't even mean so is your first day
at the store no I stayed away from it
for about two years and but you were
like did your mama
I started when I was like 17 I started
when I went to Beverly Hills High School
and I was like in uh I was in it was in
high school is at the beginning of 12th
grade and all my friends were going to
college they were taking the SAT papers
and I'm like okay now I got a start
so I just started angel Salazar actually
wrote my first joke he wrote my first
joke so he got me he got you know these
car I got these comics to start kind of
writing me jokes because I didn't know
how to write jokes and then my dad took
me to my first gig he did do you feel
pressure because it was your father or
did you feel supported because it was
your father do you know I mean it can be
either way um no he was cool you know he
was cool my dad was cool you know but I
always like you know was it was just one
of those things that I always knew I was
gonna do and like okay now I'm gonna do
it but I stayed away from the store for
two years and then there was a club
called the alley cat Bistro and that
wasn't no that was where I was my first
know the LA Cabaret was a club in the
valley you remember yeah it's not it's
not there anymore though yeah yeah like
Encino yeah so a guy named ray Bishop
who used to own an Argus Hamilton used
to get me spots there and then I worked
with Jamie at the Laugh Factory for
years really yes I stayed away from the
store and then the first time I went on
from my mom I showcased for her and then
what kind of pressure was that
terrifying yeah I was a nightmare it was
yeah that's a nightmare because I also
figure you either gonna be like no it's
no big deal or yeah it's the fucking
night no I was fucking terrible I was 19
you mean did she tell you well let me
finish okay no no so so Paul Mooney in
lieu in Paul Mooney and Louie Anderson
were sitting next to her in the booth
and her booth so I go on stage it's
packed
obviously there's like a wall full of
comics I don't wanna say they hate my
guts but it's Mitzi's son you know so
they're like in the way back so I'm like
I'm like on stage I'm doing these really
bad jokes that angel told me for me I
grew up in Beverly Hills my mom's
Mexican whatever what am i I say my
jokes no laughs so at the end I break
out and start pop locking I had this
boom box we played freakazoid
when I put this mask on my stick because
I was good at Papa yeah
so I started popping and then after I
went off stage I ended good eye for when
I'm like how do I do it just like stick
with the dancing
my mom said stick with the dancing and
then she's like get away from me it was
like pretty bad yeah so like it's not
till I became famous on MTV and I was
like drawing people in the main room
that she like made me a paid regular
really yeah yeah literally had to stay
away and then I worked with Denison for
a long time well what did you want to do
with Kinison what do you mean you worked
with an you open for him yeah I opened
for him Wow
so is that the birth of the weasel how
does the weasel cuz that the Danny I can
say it was kind of like all my friends
used to call me the weasel they did
yeah like when I was younger and then a
lot of comics like Jackson Perdue he's
just said you're a weasel mm-hmm and
then I was always like we so like I'm
the one that kind of came up with that
and then I was like if some one kid is
if that noise can actually occur what
would that noise sound like and I was
like you know that's where that the
thing came and then I started like
pausing between my words dad that was on
MTV yeah that's yeah that was like I
would look in the camera be like check
out this video bro cuz it's gonna be May
and then I would just start making shit
up right and then it was like my own
language to the audience and then and
then from there you know I was like kind
of had my own slang to the audio
wheezing the juice that was from Encino
man no so that's how it took off the
thing about it is like as a kid too you
know like somebody who's a little bit
older than you and is cool so cool and
then and then when you learn slack
because you're as a kid it's like what
does that mean yeah so like it was
hearing the slang on MTV but then in the
movies too that you're like oh man and
then you do it on the playground you
pretend to be cool crazy
Pauly Shore at school it was pretty cool
yeah it was cool yeah that's why I was
dope it was like the best I mean it was
like people always like well oh you
always hear people like oh why do you
talk about your pass on not just me just
people in general you know I mean well
sure don't you live your past I'm like
well you didn't live my past yeah yeah I
mean my past was in
saying yeah it was pretty fucking cool
so have you been on a ride that most
people will never well never will can I
ask you because I had my mother's gone
now but I had a mother who very much
disapproved of me and never really gave
me the thumbs-up the approval I so
desired like do you think there's a time
that your mother saw your career and and
went like yeah you did it yeah when I
started dressing like her pretty much I
wish I would had a daughter yeah you
know when I became famous on MTV and I
was fuck I took her the MTV Awards okay
you know I was with dating a porno star
you were so she like yeah she was like
were you dating her name was Savannah oh
I know she Ana she's popular on the
Stern Show yeah
don't they play she's been dead for a
long time she never mind oh no no but
probably mate hope I hope not no no this
was 1994 so uh yeah so yeah my mom was
cool obviously like so liberal and so
like whatever my mom never judged and
that's why I'll out that's what I loved
about my mom and that's like me like I
don't judge people like if you're a
heroin addict oh cool that's your thing
like you know mainly yeah people have to
go through what they have to go through
in life and and my mom was such you know
that my mom was such an artist like she
was so sure heart was the comics that's
where her wet sir come on and it
actually started with my dad because my
dad met her when he was touring in the
50s and my dad was touring in any and he
did a camp he did was a summer camp in
Elkhart Lake Wisconsin and my dad was
the comic there and my mom used to my
mom used to type up his jokes because
she was because she was the assistant
for the owner the owner of the camp and
she would like do this one do that so it
was like a natural thing yeah so that
was her thing ya did and that's so well
now I don't know if you've been asked
this a million times forgive me if you
have but do you have any opinion on the
Showtime series I'm dying up here I mean
um I you know I I told people a million
times exact
my take on it for people just the people
that don't know it's basically I mean
it's executive produced by Jim Carrey
and it's you know it's a play on the
store what do they call so it's like a
woman running the club I mean it's
obviously supposed to be symbolized
Mitzy
but sorry so just so people know so when
I see I tell every time I see Eric
Griffin I was like dude I'm suing you
bro
like you're playing you're playing it
wrong I'm coming after you uh-huh he's
like it's not me I'm like dude I don't
give a fuck yeah attorneys are gonna be
getting a cop no no I guess it's you
know I mean Jim Carrey you know he it's
his take on the whole thing right so
it's not my take it's not my mom's take
it's not my dad's take it's his take
that's true so that's the first thing
the second thing I look at it I look at
it at to two things I look at number one
do I like this as a show mmm you know
you're just kind of sitting there and
watching it and I think it's kind of
cool cuz I like kind of historical shows
I like shows from the 60s 70s days and
like that that era and then you look at
it as a show show not really feeling it
that much you know I mean I'm not really
connecting with people okay I think
they're all good actors yes but let's be
honest they're not all good act I mean
not not that this respects any of them
but they're not real actors they're
comedians that are acting here you and I
because I watch the whole series because
I'm in love I love the show it's about
stand-up and I know these people I think
they made it too heavy it was too
fucking dark it was like I'm gonna kill
myself if I don't get on the main with
real good actors then that would be
pretty kind of cool I know yeah I don't
know I don't know if it's acting or the
fact that I mean imagine it's like Sean
Penn's we're doing it like who was like
our generation of Sean Penn's and like
and Robert Downey and those type of guys
right right you know where they kind of
really be cleaning they should have cast
I think I don't know maybe Ryan Gosling
yeah Mike I don't know though I don't
know I don't know I think it's a fair to
I mean I like I like your take it's a
very honest take and I don't think he's
nothing wrong yeah
but I'm happy that it's got picked up
for a second season it's because it's
cool for the guys you know the guy yeah
when they got they got they got a gig
you know I mean at the end of the day
you get to fucking show up and act yeah
for fucking three months on a show yeah
what's better than that it's great you
know what I mean so the best do you yeah
do you so how did he doesn't know what
to ask me I think it's fine no no I cut
that part out so wait I want to do it
how did you know Stephen Miller think um
about when I mean obviously that
happened but how did you do they just
asked me to do it they just they just
thought I do for I do funny or die stuff
a lot so I'm always doing stuff for them
so they just Sean Boyle who's a friend
of mine over there works with Mike Farah
they're just a you know Stephen Miller
just did this thing on CNN and we want
you to play the blah blah blah and I'm
like okay and the next day I went in did
it and they put it up you know yeah what
about you guys how did you guys I mean
this is an interesting thing you're
right it's not supposed to work I mean
you mean you saw you've seen it with
your parents like two people mom wasn't
a comic you guys are full-on really good
cock comedians that are successful and
you're working this is a sitcom you got
to develop it into a show for sure we're
trying we're working on oh god it's
great financed it yourself though oh
yeah hundred percent okay yeah do it
louis c.k did except for that other no
because you can produce to get a young
producer in there and just pay for it
half half and then just shoot whatever
it is you want edit it well I think
Tommy and I work because we started at
the same time oh that's cute Tommy we
started I mean literally since he was 23
I watched him I think I met you like
when you the fifth time you went on
stage probably the same here so we're
rooting for each other it's different
than like coming in at different levels
about the Wiis is the wheezing - whoa
what the weasel is he gonna fucking
judge it when your baby resume baby came
out did you have to three minutes just
landed boys I head to port I hope not oh
my god it's definitely a show there no
thank you I mean for sure dude but who
would like I'm the road who opens for
who we don't do the road here
I think that's gonna see Natasha and
what's this I don't know how they do it
Moshe yeah but we've always had a pact
that we didn't do we didn't do that
dynamic because that's trouble yeah
better to keep it separate really I
think so that's the first episode you
guys doing it's a disaster you guys are
just filing for divorce here's a movie
premise 2018 and what's the weasel doing
now I think that would be great
well the will be doing now because we
got a fight coming up yeah I got a 50th
birthday coming up and you're gonna do a
book I should oh my god Jacques I got so
many thing I got to documentaries I have
I have about three years ago I did
stands alone which was on Showtime which
is a straight doc and now I have a doc
series based off of that and that's a
six-part series and I've finished that's
fucking I think not to Pat myself but I
think it's the best thing I've ever done
it's very emotional
I moved my mom out of the house you know
it's fucking heavy dude it's heavy
excuse me I just burped yeah it was
really gonna put a ring on this finger
or what like are you gonna with Whitney
Cummings
she keeps ignoring are you in her I just
want to get her pregnant she's really
into animals you just have to start dude
get her a horse have a horse cut I won't
say I don't know I mean I'm I'm it's
like bungee jumping for me like I kind
of like being alone I mean I have a
girlfriend now I've been seeing her for
a while okay we have a nice relationship
good but it's really difficult for me
you only mean it's difficult for me to
just be with someone I see
you know where to come home I like
coming home and I'm by myself I kind of
like that well we were just talking
about how we go away for the holidays to
avoid family I don't necessarily enjoy
hanging out with all my family members
yeah and you know that's just your
wiring and I respect that you know that
about yourself because there are some
men that aren't supposed to have
families I don't think honestly my dad
was supposed to be a family guy he
wasn't stuck around he did his duty but
I enjoyed it I was miserable
really I hear divorced my parents
divorced when I was three years old yeah
but before that I you know I have a
hammer to drive two brothers and a
sister but my oldest brother Scott he's
like 64 and my sister's like 60 she was
60 so it's like a long time do my debt
low sorry about that
my dad's fucking 90 years old my mom's
87 so it's like they were doing it a
long time ago and then they stopped and
then they had me and my brother Peter
so me and Peter were pretty much raised
at the store you know I mean the whole
time while mom was dating Argus and and
dating like Danny stone and and all
these different comedians and I was just
there running around and Argus still
visits her right like yeah he's like
very dedicated that's right yeah that's
very sweet
yeah it's very sweet he would Garry
Shandling visitor too and then he left
and he passed away not good
no why are you laughing that's not
that's politically incorrect bro this
what scene uh what movies is from one of
my favorite scenes I forget what movie
this is from of you black guys who love
to fuck and fuck good if you're a hot
black guy and you want to fuck me at
2395 if you want to move and you can
move in but you gotta fuck me
Alec right not my movie no no oh he sent
us the Republika sent us the wrong
trailer I am my publicist Oh fucking
bamboozled Holly what do you think was
going on in that clip I don't know I
don't know who I don't even know that
looked like sandy danto
oh we don't know it's a guy on the
internet who just gave out his address
and wanted black guys to come over and
fuck him and if you're out of jail do
piss on him come on and win right out
try not trying to be a little PC since
it's a family showed some other spouse
your mom yeah that's true yeah you like
music right chorus are you a fan of the
show gigolos show Tom you know it's not
seen it in a while I always seen it
well it's about there's a bunch of male
hoes on Showtime and it follows them
around you know turning their tricks and
their lives and stuff I haven't seen it
well one of the guys on there's musician
here's a new music video out and they
asked us to take a look at it so what's
your honest a cure
[Music]
clawed we chained our hearts it
never west
I love this song you do yeah I like the
song I don't know their version of its
little you know this I know this song
right it's someone else's song I don't
know no is it yeah oh it's wrecking ball
yeah yeah oh he did a remake I didn't
know that good ear
[Music]
always
are they gonna start fucking or what no
come on already one of the bang one I
adore yeah that was funny man that was
damn I miss Tony Krusty do now was Lisa
a real was it based on a real Lisa yeah
mm-hmm where's she now she lives in
Nashville with her kids yeah you're
gonna try to make a baby though right I
think so really
yeah I think that that makes sense today
yeah but I keep pulling out full loads
all the way inside yeah I'm missing the
vagina
yeah yeah right can't do a half a load
and then do out go away and you got to
make sure she lays still there after
wats are not moving
I heard if you do it doggystyle then
it's a boy and if it's standard then
it's a girl totally totally true at that
you yep so what do you guys have we have
a boy yeah so you did her dog yeah we
did you 69 we were talking about people
do people really 60 do you 69 oh I think
you do once in high school I don't do
that now guys live in a Bally house so
do you guys have sex in the valley and
stuff this is cool like you guys got
neighbors and stuff yeah no we don't
know what's gonna we have a kid I mean
where the fuck do you raise your kid I
grew up in LA I grew up out here you
grew up in the valley
I did eight one eight man till I die
Birmingham no I went to Louisville
all-girls Catholic but I had friends I
went to Birmingham
yeah so you're in the valley that's cool
but where you from originally originally
I was born in Cincinnati but I moved I
moved a lot so I lived in a lot of
Midwest got Florida
when did you start where did you start
doing your stand out here in LA which
club well I started out like some of the
bars and then I got in at Melrose first
The Improv you could say the aproblem
kiss in front of me it's okay I don't
want second you know what's what's crazy
is when I first started working The
Improv I actually put in my contract it
was two I put a curtain in front of me
because I didn't want someone to take up
a yeah
in front of the improv sign it show it
to my mom yeah sure you know because
that was like a very big you know feud
growing up as you know of course a very
important question
do you ever when you take a dump do you
ever go right to the shower like you
from shit to shower I'm not gonna talk
about that huh what a good conversation
why just to complain all the time you
think he wants to put that out there but
that's a bad energy yeah not even
whitening no because I know she's done
those jokes before onstage yeah I know
yeah but I'm just saying this is your
mom so we have to be real to the brand
yeah you know who you know who i sat
next to yesterday yeah on my flight set
directly next me was Kenya and Martin
who's that I'll tell you exactly who
that is play at the end it was a
questionable travel call and I'm saying
it didn't go our way
I mean a lot of me I always just think
of him as University Cincinnati but he
played in the NBA for I don't know a
dozen years he was a forget a bit of a
journeyman right he had a few teams me
look up his so he's retired now but I'm
saying he's let's see what his his
career was at big all fuck six nine he
played for the nets
the Nuggets the Clippers yeah bucks
a whole bunch of teams Jersey yeah yeah
do you like sports
no because the owner the all-time you
know I'm saying just came out with a lot
of ins which we knew they was gonna do
you don't saying says we always like to
really great you know sands so yeah I
think that's the open for your show you
guys talk about you're in the kitchen
you're doing the kid thing and it just
turns into like look we're getting paid
a lot of money you know and you're like
yeah but that's the one thing we talked
about we would never work together you
mean and then finally you actually let's
just do it and then it's all this angst
and you go up there and something bad
happens you don't I mean and then like
that's the end of the second act and
then the third act just like you know
you kind of deal with it and then like
you know you start
I like this premise because that is the
one thing we've chose because you know
once you do a reality show
it kills the MER no you're not reality
never script but I'm saying there's a
reason we've never done certain things I
feel like maybe unconsciously we knew
but the thing that's cool about it is
you guys are both really talented and
you guys can like do something different
because no one's done it no one's done
it successfully right the the husband
and the wife that are both true
stand-ups right I mean right well I mean
okay Lucy and Ricky they weren't
standard vaudeville they came out of
vaudeville
who's the you're right there's not been
too married true stand-ups that have
done no it would be great you just
yeah it's a good idea but you guys
already know this idea but you should
just get it done I think it'd be great
working on it we really are working
really are it's really yeah so the
reason she asked about 69 is this so you
want to talk about shitting and black
guys penises all the way over the black
guy's penis awesome have you ever seen
that website black accom no you're
talking about black penises and you
haven't seen black and calm no it's a
website dedicated to black guys having
sex with white girls you mean black
black calm yeah wait is that part of the
Dog Fart Network maybe maybe this dark
web is this stuff home but it's
basically a website that just get it
dedicated to black guys having sex with
white girls but they're hot white chicks
and they and they have sex with the
girls in the butt yeah you guys all have
tiny little dicks it's the funniest
thing it's really like a new take on it
they're like you think black guys only
have big dicks not over here and that's
why they can fit so many I probably how
many women I know asked number but I
want to ask like I feel like how many
what was it like in the it must have
been in the MTV what was crazier MTV era
or like moot like movies after that what
was a combination but like his there's
one lane of it crazier than the other or
no they both I was on TV during the
whole time I was doing the movies okay
okay it was like mixed yeah I was doing
albums yeah HBO's we're the remote
movies the whole thing the craziest like
when you go to like Daytona to do an MTV
thing about spring break
yes shit that Scott must have been off
the chain that was the best yeah like I
can't come anymore there's no more in
the I can't I know I had this friend of
mine Tony to Santa I'm gonna see in New
York yes no Tony yes you know Tony he's
a star
right is he no he's not a crazy no he's
a producer oh why don't know his name
then what did he produce he's he ran he
ran from jail homeless or wait I do know
that
random TV because I was on road rules
that's why yeah so you know tone okay
so Tony was he was like sandy dantos who
one thing sorry go ahead
he was Tony's uh he was a producer at
Spring Break when we were doing the the
chill with the Wii shows right and um
they used to come to my room the
producers would come in my room to prep
me you own a mean it's a kind of like
you know the haters are gonna do he is
on the show bo and he came in my room
and you know girls were in there already
from the night before and then he come
out and then I'm like wait dude I got a
I got and this is he says this so don't
think I'm a pig for saying this I didn't
say this he says that Paulie Lovell
bothers a splint on my dick or something
like I had a splint on my dick that's
what he said I don't remember saying
that
ask him but you know game did you have a
game setup or you'd like hey like I'm
saying like I'm saying if you I balled
someone you're working this is can't see
this he just literally rub my arm when I
felt the electricity I felt a room
that's so fucking nutty no it was um it
was cool you know it was a spring break
you had who is that Lenny Kravitz was
there rodney was down there at Kennison
was down there cheap trick was down
there black crow Stone Temple Pilots you
find them cannibals you know well you
know and it was just like you know with
live yeah that's what was cool and it
was an event Spring Break was the
biggest event for MTV so you had
hundreds of thousands of kids going and
going there just beyond Spring Break you
know it was like no and it was live so
it's like you know if you fucked up you
fucked up you know your whole you know
VJ shit yeah you know you just that's
how what did you love the gig was a
great guest yeah yeah because it was
like you felt like a rock star you know
yeah yeah I was so lucky it was very
fortunate
and that's very cool okay so the reason
she's bringing up 69 it's an important
reason so when my dad turned 70 this
summer my mother who's a foreigner she's
from Peru she we out why you have white
stuff over your nose it is we asked her
we said dad's turning 70 tomorrow we'll
use 69 in Belarus and 70 and it became
like a joke at the dinner table because
she also didn't know what that meant
right so it was like a funny thing and
people started doing it so anyways we
told our audience about that and they
have been recording their families
asking the same question and sending in
the leg job so girl 69 so before you
turn 70 like on the last night are you
gonna try to 69 one more time that's
Alec and Bailey that's fantastic she had
a good attitude yes
grandma grandma grandma are you gonna 69
movin to celebrate its just 69 see
somebody yelled him John that so that
was like yeah stop doing that a
reprimand a resume for the fun one to
celebrate his last night being 69 Dean
you guys will 69 that is fantastic
that's a good one Thank You Katie for
saying we don't usually have the women
record they've been guys been sending it
in but Katie sent it in so thank you for
that
her dad don't even with heroin it knows
a good response in here you think for
dad's 70th birthday just celebrate you
guys are gonna 69 what do you think
Devon hello yes those are my favorite
responses just like why are you being a
child like why are you doing this - you
should have pushed him alone Oh dad for
real
laris no for real you guys should it's
the last time dad 69th birthday the last
day
[Music]
so embarrassing
I don't do it but I've done it she said
look how excited dad what about the guy
little Charis guy in the corner he's
like joining Isis no it looks like my
friend Rami yeah
Rami what's up such a Brahma so that's I
was Benji we got a couple more here
Chris this is fantastic
dad's about he's not about to turn 70
but he is this 70s so he's about to be
in his 70s so the night before his 17th
birthday when he's 69 are you a 69 on
this 69 gonna do it Oh what about me I'm
49 what about me I'm gonna bet what am i
50 what is that 50 there's a big one
yeah but what do you do 50 I think you
have to you have to do sexual stuff we
do do sexual stuff what do you do have
you been pegged what does that mean like
a girl straps on a little little inputs
in my by yeah yeah but also like reaches
around and cranks went out for you
that's a big 50th thing really yeah
would you not let a girl do that maybe
if I was wasted there you go yeah you're
gonna be if I put like some muscle
relaxers in my body you have to relax
for something like that to go down I
don't do butt sex but there's a reason
yeah you know I mean yeah it's a tight
tight I love how she got really good she
said I'm gonna send you in a counseling
yeah so the night before his 70th
birthday when he's 69 are you a 69 on
his 60
counseling are you going to that's I
think that's real like they've had that
conversation Krista we're sending you
back to counseling but I like that she
did the poly technique of following up
but are you going are you gonna the
whole kid yeah you gotta push it 69 69 7
yeah it's a good time he's great I had
that clip pulled that you asked me to
pull from CNN this was in regard I think
was just about the fires that was going
on oh my god Meyers
oh no this happened in Tampa sorry in
Tampa about the serial killer an arrest
because they had a serial killer there
and killed some people earlier this year
anyways there's a sign language person
that you know they do for like big press
conferences or something so this woman
just came in and she's not a sign
language interpreter and just she did we
will be charging four counts of
first-degree murder hilarious every word
isn't that hilarious so she did it wrong
at all she's just made enough they're
having fun like she waved her arms
around like she was singing
[Laughter]
expert the woman identified as Durlan
Roberts has a string of arrests so how
did she come to be translating it last
week sigh profound like good conference
I just didn't ask enough questions Tampa
Police public information officer Steve
Haggerty told me the woman simply showed
up out of the blue and offered her
services thank oh I didn't call for a
sign language interpreter but that's
great that we have one here letter in
this woman appear to know what she was
doing to the untrained eye and I would
include mine I didn't see any problems
hilarious oh my god let's motivate
somebody is it a money with the police
yeah I'll fuck with these motherfuckers
yeah shit after it was revealed that the
sign language interpreter we won't be
using that woman again oh but it was an
ethical violation yeah that's the things
they they asked I saw that in the news
that day they're like there's nothing
like there's no charge
she's just annoyed the shit's like I
don't I can't hear the crazy sir track
her criminal record that's yeah she's
legit yeah house alarms going off hold
on our house alarm is she slammed the
door too hard
all right who's she oh boy we can talk
about her now in Chile now let's talk
sometime yeah dammit let's get those
black penises up here yeah man um so
what do you think but no yeah black
dicks yeah I watch that shit yeah it's
crazy that your site thought you'd go -
yeah that's me go - is it really yeah
cuz I'm in shock I can't believe it
how what help how hard they give it to
him that well when I was growing up we
used to watch pornos it was like a it
was uh it was like a taboo interracial
yeah just like a taboo and now it's like
the opposite
genre I mean it's like an opulent and
still bring about in a way yeah and the
anal sex is like really bizarre too
because again when I was growing up it
was like a taboo to have sex in the butt
and now like every single porno it's
like it's like a taboo to have sex in
the vagina
you own a manger it's like the vagina
just sitting there just like you know
bored yeah you're right you know I mean
it was like a first shot now it's weird
right yeah I think so
I don't know it never got into so gnarly
it wasn't into anal you know oh yeah it
is what it is it was an anal a big part
of your you know sexual exploits there's
been a couple of times but you always
have to ask the girl yeah well yeah you
can't just like put it in no and you
always make sure you have Lube on those
moments or no you got to ask the girl
really yeah sometimes you can like like
lick your finger and then put that in
and that's where that's kind of like
that's kind of like a a version of Lube
mm-hmm you only I mean if you just like
yep and then well then you just put
their intern Amy weasel it and you put
that put that put it right in the rectum
hole yeah and then you do the passing
the baton why don't you do a sex show
that's what I'm thinking yeah a sex
podcast you have season thing you have
credit
here's what works when people have
talked about a topic with them they have
credibility mm-hmm you know you everyone
knows you got laid a lot if I can talk
about it yeah you can give people tips
imagine you with like a kid he was like
I'm going to college or nervous I don't
know how do I get laid and then fucking
weasel comes in shows him what's up I
mean what would you tell some 19 year
old kid listening right now he's like I
don't know how to approach girls what do
you tell him I bet you have a good
advice I would it depends I think it's a
case by case depends on what the person
looked like yeah and what the vibe of
the person was let's say they're just a
little insecure and they are a little
overweight and they're you know they
just they just don't have any experience
so they don't know what to do but
there's cute girls walking around campus
they're like I would definitely say the
laughs thing definitely try to make them
laugh there you go I think that's
important trying to get Pauli talk
because he laughs
black penises you know if you see a
black penis just laugh at it yeah that's
what he was saying I was saying that but
he said oh you can give advice to guys
who want to get laid you know a great
idea that would be a great podcast
actually teaching dudes how to get lean
you guys can do the show this show
that's gonna be on FX cuz Louie's not
there anymore you can take that slot
right and then I can I can do my podcast
from here that's what your neighborhood
kids yeah that's a great idea
yeah I think laughing is the first and
foremost you know disarming the babes
yeah he was just saying like if there's
a 19 year old kid how and I said what's
a case-by-case like what does the kid
look like he's like his little chubby
little insecure and I'm like we'll
probably make the girl laugh something
silly always yeah you know girls always
say that horse shit on their profiles
like I just want a guy that can make me
laugh that's always number one yeah I
don't know if that's true but they say
yeah yeah they do want to make I think
the laughing thing is true that is you
gotta follow up you got to go for the
clue maybe they can also get a penis
enlargement too so one because once the
girl has a really nice penis mm-hmm
usually she goes back to it right you
know it's kind of like familiar
territory very before you were the Wiis
on MTV and I was the skis on vh1 for you
getting laid pretty well yeah yeah good
game you know hair you had the full head
of hair I don't know my mom on the
comedy starts yo yo babe come on get you
some nachos were you there all the time
even as it like as a team on because
that's it when it's even cooler I think
it's like friends are like oh let's go
drink it you know so-and-so's house but
you could like walk into the store yeah
no I used to there used to be the Comedy
Store Westwood High Romania you never
were there I think because I feel like I
remember a time when I'm very 84 or
something I know but I feel like I
remember it
existing you may not have been there I
remember it existing yeah okay well then
you remember it was right next to is an
arcade so we used to bring my friends
there we used to do whip hits watch yeah
and watch all the and watch my my
girlfriend a girl named Leslie Zeeman
from the valley
she went to Birmingham she was my prom
my prom date and my girlfriend in high
school and least have sex yeah yeah
probably she's from the valley you know
they all do that'll be good you need to
give Millennials advice because I do
another podcast called that steep bro
and I get emails from 20-year olds like
I don't know how to talk to people how
do I talk to girls how do I make friends
it's just you know it's different you
know they want to come over and yeah I
got a way to get late access a great
idea if you want to get laid
put out a thing where people know that
if they if they fuck you they could live
in your house for free so it's an
exchange of goods services you know it's
a contract contract in legal terms yeah
yeah that's a really good way to get
laid you ever get laid
that's a giveaway housing so hook cooks
men from jail homeless or you're a thug
gonna come move in a friend come home
with you man free rent utilities in a
cake oh man oh you see me when I come
over today and try it out try it out man
try out yeah we don't say I'll tell you
the secret to our joint occasionally I
do but I need you guys know how to cook
well well we do we just it's you know
who's kind of time but here's what we
decided to do that saved our
relationship
real talk even when we didn't have the
money hmm hired a fucking housekeeper
I'm talking Tommy and I were broke as a
joke we still had the $30 a week or
whatever to someone else clean up the
box or scrub those toilets on the
weekend show like that yeah it just
saves you the heartache have you ever
lived with a woman like if you had a
serious relationship kinda kinda yeah
what's the longest um this girl that
I've been with for a while
really this is the longest probably how
long is it over five years oh really
that's not get mad he's like really do
you think it's really got I mean do you
think y'all get merry little weasels
I don't know I'm very uh you know what I
mean it's very hard for me I know
especially because you you've been on
your own for so long and you're you know
I like you know I kind of go back and
forth with it you know what I mean yeah
so you know that's a real it sounds like
it's a real deep issue yes yeah do you
ever see a therapist ever done that
yeah you ever talk about that well I've
done group therapy oh no one bro get in
there I don't know a good one really
I'll recommend you two really yeah did a
girl or a boy well you wouldn't see my
therapist that's a conflict of interest
but really yeah you can't have your
friends and family sing do you want a
female or male probably female yeah I
think makes more sense for me you know
you have more lady issues than issues
with women than men let's say man I'm
I'm cool with everyone it's just as far
as like you guys live together like you
have a baby like that's full-on like
jumping in the water yeah yeah well
that's my issue
you know full-on jumping in the water
and it's like there's something I really
like about coming home and knowing no
one's gonna be there and knowing what
personal with her right it's not her at
all it's me it's like I don't know it's
just like because all day long I'm doing
stuff just like you guys are and then
you come home sometimes you just want to
be by yourself yeah you know but I guess
you know you guys do that when you're on
the road too
yeah we have a lot of old times yeah but
do you think she might give you that
space like when you came home like give
you an hour to yourself yeah yeah of
course but right now I'm staying in an
apartment
it's Silver Lake so it's gonna like it's
a one-bedroom apartment so it's not
really conducive right right
oh right I mean it's like it's not like
a big house yeah you know but I think it
is scary to get married and it is scary
to get this responsible with the jumping
in the
yeah well cuz I remember when Tom and I
first got married there were times when
I felt like I had a run like if we
fought or something I'd be like I gotta
go head for the hills and I think that's
like a childhood thing that I had to
resolve in therapy obviously I don't
feel that way now Tommy but it's a
process you know I think it's a process
it doesn't it's not normal if you're
especially handsome when all the times
well it's I think it's a growing process
you know especially if you've got some
stuff that needs to be resolved or
whatever it's my shoe sense yeah I'd
love for you to go therapy and talk
about real quick before you go I know
he's got to go too
oh yeah oh yeah there's an email about
King a stripper says mommies I was
visiting the a stripper catalog and had
a thought my old roommate was lactose
intolerant to such a degree that he got
terrible gas pains every time he drank
milk how funny it's tied into the other
thing the volume and consistency of
these farts were similar they're not
equal to the Kings I believe this may be
how the King is able to muster these
mythical farts Josh you know about King
a stripper no he's a internet sensation
and he makes this is why I want to get
out of the entertainment business yeah
for this type of she caused it because
well you're like he's celebrity on the
thing oh yeah I can't keep up with this
though no I know talent though
[Music]
he loves it he loves it just really
tickles me prospects for getting laid
you don't I mean yeah I see I don't
think it's funny at all I think it's
funny that you guys think it I know that
hilarious that you guys even putting
this on your show he's like a pig he's
into it yeah really into it he also does
a lot of glutton videos big ass fucking
breakfast for bean and cheese burritos
lathered with two big-ass eggs and
fucking sick sausage and cheese patties
oh look at that he gets kicked off a lot
of the platforms that he's on alright so
then he'll he'll pass sneak around he'll
sneak around so he'll be on liveleak and
they'll go back to YouTube then he's on
just like the e bombs and he's back on
my I fart in yo face as one of his
handles or hairy and gross but I think
you should look him up he's really
talented
[Laughter]
[Music]
aurilla can act in movies and create a
persona Y become a cultural phenomenon
or you just farted on the internet not
for me
alright but I mean I appreciate it I'm
happy that he's got so many views yeah
and you could donate if you want him to
eat something for you on camera or for
it for you he'll take your donations
okay yeah so look Thank You first of all
for coming over I know you got to go to
this game it was seriously fun to hear
the insight on a lot of the stuff man
seriously so your advice is to go the
fuck away if you ever get your hugely
successful go away from things so you
gotta you gotta you know especially when
your representatives and people around
you and but I don't know I think that uh
you know we're you're lucky to catch
fire on anything in this business you
know you catch up catch a wave and if
you get as big as I got you know like so
like like this it's good to go away yeah
yeah I think so too it's great advice
yeah you can see a bunch of paulie's
videos on Funny or Die he's done it he's
done a number of them and you can catch
him on tour you have any upcoming when
is this gonna air this comes out
tomorrow man oh shit
okay I'll be at the st. Louis funny bone
this weekend oh great st. Louis funny
bone yeah it's a great it's actually the
first funny bone is it really yeah the
first one yeah all right it smells like
it too which is awesome yeah that's they
still smoke in there sometimes they like
a smoking show they'd be like The Early
Show those smoke and then I'm bringing
Josh Martin with me he's great he's good
who do you guys who opens for you guys
when you don't you bring someone you go
by yourself I sometimes bring Matt
foolish Ron Joe bartnik Jeff Tate
I brought Josh Potter to a bunch of gigs
this year he's from Buffalo but lives
here now yeah very funny very funny yeah
there's other guys too that brought but
like this year Potter we're gonna find
you a girl we're if I'm me a girl and a
fat unattractive unfuckable not like I'm
saying he's about to yeah he's like I
got for you they're all that works that
oh she's great good I know you're
talking about she's really funny she's a
big lesbian girl yes yes we'll talk
about her she's fantastic
yeah thank you for coming today thank
you and also thank you guys for
listening of course here is your song to
go out lift your jeans up higher
is this is this guy's gonna fart on us
Jason from Sacramento thanks so much
all right guys see you next time thank
you that with Masie natural crouches I'm
fine
put your camel toe kick no so keep them
high in time you sexy tiger I wanna see
those thighs explode now turn around so
I can see your entire fucking drop and
forgive me if you see my mouth water
don't mean to be rude I just want me to
fine cuz I've been starving myself in
for some bone Chung tonight and if you
don't give me my appetizer with some
stinky sauce I think I'll just die but
not come back in reincarnation
[Music]
that's your genes